All right, you guys, let's
go ahead and get started.
I am back.
I know you guys all
missed me.
Just a couple of announcements.
Since you guys didn't have
recitations this week.
I want to make sure that
you guys remember the Design
Project 2 proposals
are due next tomorrow
in class, as is Hands On 6.
Also, Quiz 2 is graded and
is ready to be handed back.
If you go to office hours
with your TA this afternoon,
you can pick it up or you
can get it in class tomorrow.
We will post the statistics
as soon as we get them.
We are still waiting to get
the scores from one of the TAs
into the thing, so I do
not want to say anything
until we know for sure.
All right.
What we have seen so
far, we saw last time,
we talked about this
notion of transactions,
we talked about the
notion of making
actions durable and consistent.
This time what we
are going to do
is look at a related topic, a
slightly more advanced topic
that is more related to the
notion of atomic actions
that we spent two or
three lectures previous
to the one about
transactions talking about.
If you remember,
an atomic action,
we say it is both
recoverable and isolated.
When we say an action
is recoverable,
that means, remember,
it either all happens
or it does not happen at all.
When we say an
action is isolated,
it means, from the point
of view of other actions
that are running
concurrently in the system,
the action appears
to only be one unit.
So then none of the intermediate
states of the action
is visible to any other actions
that are running concurrently.
And we talked about the
use of the logging protocol
to allow us to recover actions.
We also, in the
text and in class,
talked briefly about version
histories as an alternative way
that we can recover actions.
And we talked about
how to do isolation.
We talked about several
different methods
for doing isolation.
We spent a while talking
about locking as a mechanism
that we use to isolate
actions from each other.
What we are going to talk
about today is a related topic,
and it has to do with
when you have actions
that are spread
across multiple sites,
multiple different computers.
And this is going to tie
together some of the concepts
that we learned in the
previous section on networking
with the more recent stuff
that we have been talking
about with atomic action.
The topic today is
multi-site atomicity.
And just to give you a
simple example of what
we mean by a situation
in which you might care
about multi-site
atomicity, suppose that you
are running a travel website.
You have some travel
site, and that
travel site you have
negotiated agreements
with various different people
who sell airline tickets.
Maybe you have agreements
with Jet Blue and USAir
and some other set of airlines.
And you want to make it so
that when somebody purchases
a ticket, they may purchase
a set of flights that
are purchased together
as one unit where
there are different flights
on different airlines.
I might want to purchase
a flight from here
to San Francisco
on JetBlue and then
a flight from San Francisco
back to here on USAir.
Sometimes people want to use
multiple different vendors
when they are purchasing
their tickets.
And it may be the way that your
travel site talks to JetBlue
and USAir is over the Internet.
They use some remote
procedure call
to ask JetBlue or USAir to
reserve a seat on their behalf.
But when somebody is
using your website,
you want to create the illusion
that these reservations that
are made on the website are
sort of one atomic unit.
You do not want it to
be that a person gets
a reservation on
JetBlue and does not
get a reservation on USAir.
You want them to
make a reservation
and get all of the reservation
or none of the reservation.
In order to make
that work, we are
going to need some
sort of special support
from the travel site,
JetBlue and USAir.
Suppose, for example, I did
not have any special support
from the JetBlue
website and I said
I want to purchase this
ticket to San Francisco.
JetBlue goes ahead
and says I am ready
and I purchased
that ticket for you.
And then suppose we cannot
get this reservation on USAir.
Now we are in trouble.
We need some way to back out
of the action with JetBlue
and say wait, never
mind, I did not
mean to actually
purchase that ticket
because I could not complete
the rest of my purchase.
We are going to talk about how
to provide this kind of, what
we call, multi-site
atomicity where
we want this whole action that
includes purchases of tickets
from these different websites
to appear as though it
was one atomic action.
Particularly we want to make
sure that this whole thing is
both recoverable and isolated.
To sneak up on this
topic, because there
are a bunch of different issues
that are going to come up here
and are going to be a
little bit complicated,
we are going to start
by looking at a simpler
version of this problem.
Let's suppose that we have
all of these things running
on the same computer
together, that is they
are not connected
over the Internet,
there is not this possibility of
a message being lost like there
would be on the Internet.
So we are going to
look at these things
as though they are all running
together on the same computer.
In that case, we call
these actions that
are running together
on the same computer
"nested atomic actions".
Once we see how this works
on just the single computer
case then we will
sort of look and see
how it gets more complicated
when we extend it out
to the multi-computer case.
Let's simplify
this a little bit.
Suppose we had our buy ticket
procedure looking something
like begin, buy on JetBlue,
then buy on USAir and then end.
I am just going to call these
two things A and B for now
just to sort of simplify it so
I do not have to write JetBlue
and USAir over and over again.
And the property that we want is
that each one of these actions,
in and of itself, should
be atomic with respect
to the other actions.
We want atomic with
respect to each other.
That is one property we want.
We want that because,
for example, suppose
that buying JetBlue requires
me to provide some credit card
number or debit card number that
is going to go out and purchase
the ticket.
Well, I do not want to
have the action that
purchases from JetBlue and
the action that purchases
from USAir simultaneously
decrementing my,
say, bank account.
Because we saw how you could
imagine getting into trouble
where they would both read
the balance at the same time
and then both decrement and then
both write at the same time.
You could get some mixed up
balance left in your bank
account, for example.
So if these things are,
let's say, for example,
debiting a bank
account, you want
to make sure that these actions
are atomic with respect to one
another.
You also want to make sure
that this whole thing is
atomic with respect
to the outside world.
That is to say that
the caller, somebody
who invokes this procedure
to buy this pair of tickets
never gets to see a state where
one of the tickets is purchased
and one of the tickets
is not purchased.
It either looks like the ticket
has been completely purchased
or it has not been
purchased at all,
so we want it to be isolated.
And we also want it
to be recoverable.
We want it to be the case
that if we crash halfway
through here, after we have
bought the ticket on JetBlue,
if the whole system
crashes at that point, when
the system comes back up,
we do not want the system
to be in some
halfway state where
we paid the money for
the JetBlue ticket
and have not paid the
money for the USAir ticket.
So we should either
complete the transaction
or we should completely
roll back the transaction
and abort it.
So this is this notion of
nested atomic actions, which
is we have this outer
action and then it
has these two actions
that are nested within it.
And each of these actions
is, in and of itself,
an atomic action.
If you think about what's
going on here for a minute,
so if you think about what the
sort of condition that we want
is, we've got A and B.
And we want A to
commit if B commits
and we want B to
commit if A commits.
Because, if A doesn't commit,
we need both of these actions
to definitely commit or
definitely not commit.
Otherwise, we're kind of in
trouble for this example.
But the way that
I've worded this,
it kind of sounds
impossible, like how
is it A is waiting
for B to commit
and B is waiting for A to
commit so how are we ever going
to make any progress?
And the trick is
that we're going
to introduce a third-party,
something that is
in charge of deciding whether
or not the entire action has
committed.
So we're going to
introduce a node S which
we call the "supervisor".
And S is in charge of
deciding whether or not
the entire action, the action
with both A and B inside of it
actually commits.
So let's see how that
works because just seeing
that we still have
to have some way of S
knowing that A is
ready to commit
and S knowing that B
is ready to commit.
And we still need
some way of making it
so that A and B both make
the decision to commit
at exactly the same time.
So let's see how we can
go about doing that.
The idea is that we're
going to introduce something
we call "tentative commits".
So what we want to
do is get A and B
to a point where they're
both exactly ready
to commit but they haven't
yet actually committed
their results.
So they haven't actually
made their results available,
but they want to give up
control to S as to the instant
that they'll actually commit.
So what we're trying
to get is a way
in which S can instantaneously
make a decision
about whether both A and
B commit or neither A
or B commits.
And so what we're
going to do is,
the idea with a
tentative commit is
we're going to run A and B
until they tentatively commit.
And what that means is
that they're going to do,
so we want A and
B to do everything
except actually commit.
So what does that mean?
It means that A and B are
going to read all of the data
that they would
normally read, they're
going to write all the things
that they would normally write.
If we are using a locking
protocol they would acquire
all of the locks that they
would need to acquire in order
to process the
transaction, process
their part of the action.
But they're not actually
going to commit.
So not committing means
that, in particular, they
are not going to expose
their results out
to the outside world.
So we say they don't
expose results beyond S.
So a tentatively
committed transaction,
I'm just going to
write as TC, says
that it's not
going to expose any
of the results of its
action outside of S.
If we're using a
locking protocol,
how do we prevent one
of these nested actions
from being able to
expose its results?
Or, how do we make it so that
it doesn't expose its results
or it makes its results
visible outside?
Yeah.
STUDENT: Whenever a stop
action wants to commit,
we would just move the lock
to its higher level of action,
to the action it belongs to.
Right.
That's essentially what
we're going to want to do.
If we just want to make it
so that the action's results
aren't visible, we're
just going to make it
so that that action doesn't
release any of its locks.
If it doesn't release
its locks then
nobody else can get locks on
any of the data that it updated.
And, therefore, none of its
updates will be visible.
The solution that
was proposed here
is what we're going
to work up to,
which is that basically we want
to make sure that if we want
S to be able to see the
results of a tentatively
committed sub-action, which
we will and I'll explain why.
Then what we're
going to do is we're
going to hand the locks
off from the sub-action
up to S, the superior action.
We're work through
how that works.
The way that this
is going to work,
this is going to
allow us to get,
so we can draw a graph
that looks like this.
We say S, we've got some action
A, we've got some action B,
and we may, in principle,
have other actions
that are sub-actions
of these sub-actions.
And what we're
going to do is we're
going to draw a graph
where we put arrows
pointing from the
sub-action up to its parent
action, the action that
it is depending on.
And we're going to
label the states,
we can label each
one of these actions
in this graph as either
tentatively committed.
Or, if it's not
tentatively committed,
it hasn't finished doing
all of its processing
yet we might label
it as pending.
Let's look in a
little bit more detail
about how we might actually
get this tentative commit thing
to work.
And hopefully that will
make it a little bit more
clear what's going on here.
And, in particular,
what I want to do
is I want to look at
the way in which a log
action on this machine
might be being maintained.
And this is really going
to help us get at how
we do recovery via logging.
This is for these
nested actions.
Suppose we have some log
and this has actions in it.
When S first starts
running the transaction,
when the transaction first
starts running this supervisor
module writes a begin
transaction message.
And then what it's
going to do is
it's going to invoke each one
of these subatomic actions.
And each one of those
subatomic actions
is going to write a
begin record as well.
And then there's going
to be some processing,
so these actions are
going to execute,
they're going to
obtain some locks
and they are going
to update some data.
We're going to write those
log records for that data that
was updated into the log.
And then, at some
point later, we
will see tentative commits for
A and tentative commits for B.
And then finally
what we'll do is,
once those guys are
tentatively committed,
we'll write the
commit record for S.
Now let's look at what we
can say at various points
sort of during it.
If you think of this log as
being a timeline about when
things happen in
the system, let's
look and see what we can
say at various points.
One thing we can say is that
this time when this commit
S record was written,
this is the commit point
for this entire transaction.
So we say this is the commit
point for both A and B
and anything else
that maybe S did.
If you remember, what
the commit point is,
it's sort of the
point of no return.
Once we reach the
commit point we've
guaranteed that this
action is going to persist.
Even if the system crashes,
it will recover in the state
as though that action
had taken effect.
And if we crash prior
to the commit point
then what we want to guaranty
is that this action was not
visible.
When we recover we're
going to undo any effects
that anything in
this action did.
If we were to crash
right here, just
before we wrote
the commit record,
then we would undo
this whole action.
And if we were to crash
any time after we write
the commit record
then we're going
to make sure that we redo any
updates that the action may
have needed to do.
We're going to guaranty that
this action is forced to disc.
But notice that there are these
two tentative commit records.
What do these tentative
commit records correspond to?
What these tentative
commit records mean
is that A and B, this buy
JetBlue and buy USAir,
did all of the work
that they had to do.
So, in particular, it means
that neither A or B is going
to have to acquire
anymore locks,
they're not going to
write anymore data.
They're at exactly this point
where they're ready to commit.
And the thing that's
going to make them commit
is the writing of this
commit S log record.
Effectively, A and B,
the sort of whether
or not A and B commit is now
out of control of A and B
once they write this log record.
And it's completely in the hands
of this outer supervisor module
S.
And so the outer
supervisor module
S, of course it can
commit, but you also
have to realize that it's also
OK if this outer module aborts.
And if it aborts then it will
write an abort log record
and we will have to go and undo
the effects of the whole thing.
But we can still do that because
we haven't, as of this point
here, actually exposed any
results outside of this action.
So there is nobody else who has
seen the effects of this thing.
We're still isolated
with respect
to any outside action that
might be running on the system.
So it's OK if we abort any
time up to this commit record.
It also means that
after this commit point,
this is sort of the
point where we're going
to start exposing results.
If we're locking we're going
to release our write locks
after this commit point.
And the act of
releasing the locks
is what's going to make
it so that other actions
outside of this system can see
the effects of A and B running.
Just to make it clear, we
say A and B commit or abort
when S commits or aborts.
I have just written CA
here for commit or abort.
There is one other
little detail that we
need to point out
which is that S
can commit even if A or B fail.
So this may seem a little
bit counterintuitive,
but the intuition here
is that this action S,
suppose that S tries to run
A and it cannot get a hold
of the tickets on
JetBlue that it wanted.
Well, S is free to go and
try and make a reservation
on some other airline that also
satisfies the user's request.
So the fact that A failed
doesn't say anything about
whether or not S is
necessarily going to fail.
S still gets to decide
whether it fails or not.
And this is kind of
an important property
because it means that these
actions that are running inside
of S are actually,
while they are running,
are isolated with respect to
S and the other actions that
are running on S.
Any of the updates that they
make while they're running
aren't seen by S or any
of the other actions.
This is just one little
thing to keep in mind.
There is one last detail that
I've sort of brushed over here
that we hinted at a
little bit a minute ago.
And that's the problem which
is what if A and B conflict
with each other?
We said that A and B might both
update the same bank account
balance, right?
Well, we have a little
bit of a problem
if that happens
because I've got my S
and I've got my A and my B.
And it may be the
case that suppose
we start running A first, A gets
the lock on the bank account
and then B starts
running and tries to get
the lock on the bank account.
And it waits for A
because A is still holding
this lock on the bank account.
So we may have this
situation where
B is waiting for A to release
the lock on the bank account.
But the way that I've
described this so far,
it may not be clear
that B is ever
going to be able to
actually obtain the lock.
Because we said that these
tentatively committed actions
don't release their locks
until after the commit point
has been reached.
It turns out that we need to
sort of modify that statement
just a little bit.
And that kind of
gets to the comment
that was made before
which points this out.
What we want to say is
that when an action like A
tentatively commits,
we want to make it
so that S and its children
can see A's updates.
After A has
tentatively committed,
the other actions
that are underneath S
should be able to see
the updates that A made.
So A is going to go ahead
and withdraw the money
from the bank account, and then
it's going to say OK, I'm done,
I've withdrawn my money.
And now any other
action within S
that needs to run
that maybe also needs
to update the bank
account will be allowed
to go ahead and do that.
So B could go ahead and run
and update the bank account.
Notice that we haven't
said that A's updates are
visible outside of S.
Nobody else gets to see
that this bank account
balance got changed.
It's just the action B that gets
to see that the bank account
balance is going to change.
Effectively, what
this amounts to
is that when A
tentatively commits
it assigns all of its
locks up to the S action.
That's as much as
I'm going to say
about this notion of
nested atomic actions.
What this has given us
is this way to have,
on a single site,
one action that
is composed of
multiple sub-actions
where those sub-actions are
isolated from each other.
And all of the sub-actions
either commit or abort
together as a batch.
But we said what we
ultimately wanted
was the ability to do this
across multiple sites.
Just to draw a simple
architecture diagram
about the multi-site case
seeing what this looks like,
suppose we have some
action S and suppose
we still have our A and our B.
Now, just to conceptualize
this, suppose
that there is some network in
the middle of these things.
And this is a
best-effort network
so it has all the problems
that we talked about
that best-effort networks have.
It has congestion, it has
delays, it can lose packets.
And the way to think
about these things
is that these actions are going
to interact with each other.
These nodes are going to
interact with each other using
RPCs.
And they're just
going to send actions,
they're just going
to send requests
to each other and
responses over these links.
So S is going to send RPC to A
saying reserve a seat for me,
for example, and then A
is going to send a reply
back saying OK, I went ahead
and reserved that seat.
So what I want to
do is sort of go
from this informal
description of what
we want in the multi-site case
to an actual description of how
the protocol works so you
guys can see that there
are some pretty subtle details
that are involved in this.
And it's worth pointing out
that this situation is fairly
similar to many of
the things that, some
of the problems
that you're going
to have to deal with in the
context of the design project
so it probably is a good idea
for you to pay attention.
So let's talk about how
this protocol would work.
The idea here is we
want to provide --
Suppose we're still in this
same travel site example.
The client wants to make these
reservations over this network,
and the protocol we're going
to use is a protocol called
"two-phase commit".
Suppose we have our node
S which is the coordinator
node, the node that
represents the travel site,
and we also have our two
worker nodes that correspond
to JetBlue and USAir A and B.
I just want to show
that each of these sites
is going to maintain
a bit of a log that
reflects the state of the
actions that it's running.
So I'm going to show
the state of the log
on each of these nodes.
Suppose at some time S
starts executing this action,
let's call it T, so it's going
to write a log record that
says start T, and
then it's going
to request that each of
the subordinate nodes,
the sub-nodes goes ahead
and does the processing,
say purchases the
ticket that it wants.
It is going to send a message
here saying, for example,
say the message consists
of do something,
do X, purchase this ticket.
And, at the same
time, it may also
send a message to B telling
it to do something else.
Say, for example, do Y.
Now what's going to happen
is that each of these guys
is going to receive this
request to do something,
so it's going to write a
log record that says start.
It's going to keep some
information about what
it started doing,
it's going to say X,
and it's going to remember
that maybe this was
a part of transaction T.
And, similarly,
this guy is going
to start Y which was a
part of transaction T.
And then these two As
and Bs now are just
going to start
executing the action
that they were asked to execute.
So they are going to, for
example, purchase the ticket.
They're going to run.
They're going to
acquire whatever
locks that they need
to process and then
they are, at some point,
going to enter the tentatively
committed state.
The same thing is going
to happen over here.
They are both going
to run these actions.
When they reach the
tentatively committed state,
what they're going
to do is they're
going to send a message back
that says something like did X?
This message is
sometimes called a vote.
Basically it says
whether or not this site
agrees that it was able
to finish the work that it
was able to do.
So if it votes yes that means,
yes, I'm done, I'm ready to go.
And if it votes no
that means sorry,
I couldn't do the
thing that you wanted.
So similarly B is going to send
back its vote that says did Y.
So let's suppose, in both these
cases, both of these actions
were able to do the work
that they wanted to do.
At this point now
what's going to happen
is that S is going to look
at the votes from the actions
that it is tasked, and it's
going to decide whether or not
this action is going to commit
or is not going to commit.
So S is the one that's
responsible for deciding
whether or not this
entire action commits.
And suppose it decides
it's going to commit,
it's going to
write a record that
says commit this transaction T.
So this is now the commit point.
As soon as S writes
the commit record, that
means this action
is going to commit,
it's going to be made
visible to the outside world,
all the work has been done.
And it's OK if it does
this because A and B are
both in the tentatively
committed state.
They've said I'm
ready to go, I've
done all the work I need to
do, I can commit whenever
you tell me it's OK to commit.
So, after this point,
everything is going to commit.
The reason this is called the
two-phase commit protocol,
typically this part
is called phase one
where we're deciding whether
or not we agree to commit.
And then here in this next
step we enter phase two.
So what do we have
to do in phase two?
Notice that these guys
have tentatively committed.
A and B don't actually
know whether or not
the action has committed
so they don't actually
know whether they should
release their locks
and make their updates
visible to the outside world.
So we need to make sure that
S tells A and B that OK,
this action is done, I've
committed and it's OK for you
to also go ahead and commit
and expose your results
to the outside world.
This is slightly different
than the protocol
we looked at before
because these things are
on different machines and so
we have to pass information
from S to A and B to let
them know that this action is
ready to go.
S is going to send a
message to A saying commit,
A is going to write a log
record that says commit,
and then it's going
to do the same thing,
send the message to
B that says commit.
And, similarly, B
is going to write
a log record that says commit.
This is the basic
two-phase commit protocol.
If you count the number of
messages that you see here,
if you have N sites,
the number of messages
you have to send
in two-phase commit
is 3N in the basic
protocol without any loss.
Notice I haven't said
anything about what
happens when a message is lost.
And remember these
best-effort networks
have this property that messages
can be lost, we can lose data,
so we want to make
sure that we understand
how this protocol works in
the face of data being lost.
The other thing
that we need to do
is to make sure
that we understand
how this protocol
works in the event
that either S crashes
or A and B crash
at different points in the
execution of the protocol.
So that's what we're going
to talk through now, sort
of these nitty-gritty
details about how we actually
get this thing to work in
the face of these properties
that best-effort
networks introduce.
To remind you guys
how we deal with loss
in best-effort
networks, I am just
going to very quickly
review exactly
once RPC protocol that we
talked about a few weeks ago.
Exactly once RPC
remember is a way
to make it so that a procedure
call gets executed once,
a remote procedure call gets
executed once, and only once,
between a client and a server.
So if we've got our
client and our server,
what we do is keep
at the client,
we keep a list of
messages, at the server
we keep a list of "nonces."
The client sends a request,
a message, for example,
to the server asking
it to do something
and it attaches a
nonce to it, say N1.
So the client puts in its
message table message,
N1 stores that information.
The server receives
this request,
it stores the nonce in
its nonce table and, one,
sends an acknowledgement
and processes the request.
The acknowledgement comes
back, and maybe it's
lost because these are
best-ever networks.
Remember we have this timeout.
After some timeout period
the client resends.
This is message, N1 again.
When the message gets
resent, the server
checks to see if this message
is already in its nonce table.
If it is, it doesn't process
the message again but it sends
the [ACE?] for that message.
Now this [ACE?]
message gets received,
the client crosses it off its
message list because it knows
it's done processing.
That's the basic exactly
once RPC protocol.
And what this guarantees is
that this persistent client is
going to retry
sending the request
until it gets an
acknowledgement.
And the problem with that is
that it can generate multiple,
the server can hear this
message multiple times
so the server uses this
nonce table to filter out
duplicate messages.
Let's see how we can use this
notion of this exactly once
in our two-phase
commit protocol.
I'm going to erase this and just
redraw a similar example with
a [LOSI?] protocol instead
of a [LOSLS?] protocol.
And just to sort of make the
notation a little bit simpler,
let's now just suppose we
have one worker site A.
We're not going to show A or B.
But this generalizes completely
to as many As, Bs, Cs as we
want.
What's going to happen
now is, what I want to do
is I want to keep a list
of pending actions at S,
as well as the log of NS.
And I'm also at A going
to keep a list of pending
actions and the log at A.
At some point S is going
to go ahead and start
processing the transaction
again and it's going to write
start T.
It's going to add T to its
list of pending actions.
And then it's going to send this
message that says do X to A.
Of course, it may be the case
that this message gets lost
because this is a
[LOSI?] network.
So we're just going
to use our persistent.
We're going to
make S persistently
retry so some time later,
after some timeout,
it's going to resend
this do X message.
And it knows that
it needs to timeout
because it sees that
there is this action here
that's still pending.
Now this site A is going
to receive this request.
It's going to add
X for transaction T
to its pending list, it's
going to write its start
X of T record, and it's
going to go ahead and process
just like it did before
until it tentatively commits.
And now, once it is
tentatively committed,
it's going to go ahead and
mark this in its pending
table this action is
tentatively committed
and it's going to send a
request back that says did X.
Of course, this request
can also be lost.
So, again, remember we have the
server persistently retrying.
So, at some point, it didn't
hear this did X request.
It's just going to
say hey, do it again.
And now when A
receives this request,
it's going to look up
in its pending table,
it's going to see that it has
already tentatively committed
this action.
So it's just going to not
process the action at all,
it's just going to send
back the request that says,
this should say do X,
it's going to say did X.
Now, once S has received the
tentative commits from all
of the other actions, it
can go ahead and write
its commit record and we can
go ahead and enter phase two,
just like we did before.
You can kind of see how
this is going to work out.
The process is just going
to continue in the same way.
After S writes
its commit record,
it's going to go ahead and
send the commit message.
And, of course, it is possible
for the commit message
to be lost.
So, in this case, notice that
the server doesn't actually
know whether the commit
message has been lost or not.
And we haven't shown A
sending out any responses
back to the server after the
commit message has been sent.
So that means that A is
the one that actually
has to retry in this case.
Now, A is just going
to say hey, S, I did X.
And that's OK.
Now what's going
to happen is S is
going to go ahead and
look up in its table, when
it wrote the commit
message to change
the state of this message to
committed, this transaction
to committed, so S is just
going to look up in its table,
see that the
transaction is committed
and is going to send
this message again.
And now, hopefully, this
time it gets through.
And S can go ahead and change
the state of this action
to committed, it can release its
locks and the protocol is done.
One thing to note
is that as soon
as A knows that the
action is committed,
it doesn't need to keep any
more state about the action
around anymore.
It knows it's committed.
That means that S has
definitely heard about the fact
that it did X.
And so A can go
ahead and just forget
any information it had in
this pending transaction
table about the action.
We haven't quite
solved the problem
but we still, in S, have to
keep this information around
about the fact that the
transaction committed
because we never
actually know, in S,
whether this final commit
message got through or not.
So it's always possible
that A could re-request
the state of transaction T.
And S needs to be able
to answer that correctly.
So this complicates
this a little bit,
and there are a
couple of solutions
that people have proposed.
The obvious one is we
just add an extra round
of acknowledgements
onto the end of this.
So that's a simple thing we can
do, is just have A acknowledge
that it heard the message.
And then, as soon as S
has heard acknowledgements
from all of its
subordinates, it can go ahead
and delete the information.
There is another
variant of this,
which is talked about a
little bit in the text,
something called
presumed commit where
basically if A doesn't know
anything about the action,
it assumes that the
action committed.
So A can discard the fact
about any committed actions.
Getting that to work is
a little bit trickier.
And the details of it are
a little bit complicated
but you can sort
of see the idea.
I just want to quickly spend
a couple of minutes talking
about what happens in the
case when these systems crash
during different
phases of execution
so you guys can get a
sense of how recovery
would work in this environment.
Let's suppose that S crashes.
And there are two situations
we're worried about.
Either it crashes before commit
or it crashes after commit.
If it crashes before
commit that means
that, S is the sort of
lead transaction here,
we want to treat
this just like we
would treat this in sort
of traditional recoverable
systems.
So if we crash before
the main commit, well,
what we want to do is undo the
effects of this transaction
completely.
So we're going to undo T.
Notice, however, that if
there are multiple As,
Bs and Cs it may be the
case that S crashes and some
of the subordinates are still
processing messages and send
did finish processing
requests to S.
That means when S crashes it
recovers, it comes back up,
it undoes the transaction and
it remembers that T aborted.
So it puts T in its
transaction table
so that when it gets a request
from somebody saying hey,
I finished doing this
part of transaction T,
it can tell that guy oh, by the
way, that transaction aborted.
Now, suppose that we crashed
after the commit, well,
you know what's going to happen.
We want this transaction
to be durable.
We said that the commit
is the commit point,
we want this thing to
appear to have happened.
So we need to make sure
that we run redo on T
and that we remember
that T committed.
Now, if A crashes, the situation
is a little bit easier.
Basically, there are
only two situations
we have to worry about in A.
It's either before
or after we've
gone into the
tentative commit state.
If it's before the
tentative commit state,
well, we're just going to undo
the effects of this transaction
completely.
We're going to roll
it back and basically
going to forget about it.
And it's going to be
S's responsibility
to try and redo this action
with us, if it wants to,
or S may go ask somebody else
to do this part of the action.
If we crashed after
the tentative commit,
though, remember that at
this point it's up to S.
This is A crashes.
At this point it's up to S.
So, after we've reached
the tentative commit,
this action needs to go
ahead and check with S
and see what the final
outcome of this thing was.
It crashes, it comes
back up, it sees
it was in the tentative
commit state for T,
and so it sends a
message to S saying
hey, whatever happened to T?
And then S sends a
response back if it knows.
This is the basic outline
of how we do crash recovery
and how we deal
with lost messages
in this two-phase
commit protocol.
With the last few minutes, I
want to talk about something.
This two-phase commit
protocol seems really great.
It seems like we
got in this way we
have actions that
are distributed
across multiple sites.
We've made it so that
if the action commits,
we have this nice property
that if the action commits,
we can make it so that
either A or B don't commit
or they definitely both commit.
We have this way in which
S is the ultimate arbiter
and authority of what commits.
This seems like a really
nice system that we built.
And it is.
And it has all these
great properties,
but there is one property
that it doesn't have.
The question is, say in this
environment with A and B,
do they make their results
visible at the same time.
I had written commit before.
And, in some sense, they
do commit at the same time
because they're going to
definitely commit at the point
that this record gets written.
But the answer to the question
are there results visible,
the question is
are there results
visible at the same time, if
you stare at this for a little
while you realize no
because their results
become visible at the point
at which these A and B receive
the commit message from S.
Not at the point that S
writes the commit record.
So they're going to expose their
results at a slightly different
point in time.
And, in fact, it
could be a long time
because it may be that
A crashed after it went
into the tentative commit
record and it took it
two days to recover.
And then it came back up
and then it checks with S
and says hey, whatever
happened to T?
So it could be a very
long time before, say,
A commits, makes
its results visible,
whereas B may have
done immediately
after it received the first
commit message from S.
You might ask the question
is it possible to guaranty
that A and B expose their
results to the outside world
at exactly the same instant.
And the answer to this
question, it turns out, is no.
And this is kind of
a fundamental result.
The reason for this,
let me just give you,
there's a simple example that's
talked about in the book.
It's called the "two
generals problem".
And the idea is as follows.
Suppose there are two generals
and they have their armies.
They've flanking somebody
who they are attacking
and they're on the
sides of a valley
and they're both going to dive
into the valley with the armies
at the same time.
They're trying to
agree what time they're
going to do this at.
And they want to make sure they
both attack at the same time
because, if they don't
attack at the same time,
they're afraid that
one of them will lose.
So the only way they
have to communicate
with each other is by
sending these messengers,
say, across the valleys.
They have some guy
who runs across.
But, of course, this
guy may not make it.
He may collapse from exhaustion
or he may get shot or whatever.
So the first general
sends a runner out
to the second general that
says we'll attack at dawn.
And maybe that
runner gets through.
And then the second general
sends a runner back that
says yes, we'll attack at dawn.
And maybe that runner gets
through, or maybe he doesn't.
The second runner
doesn't get through,
and the first
general says man, I
don't know if the second
general heard about this or not.
So he sends another runner
that says we'll attack at dawn.
And the second general says
I already sent a runner
but I guess he
didn't get through
and he sends another one back.
And, ultimately, they
both need to agree
that they'll both
attack at dawn so you
need a certain number of
runners to successfully get
through in order
for this to happen.
The issue here,
though, is that suppose
the general have a
fixed number of runners
and they want to say what's
the maximum number of runners
that I could possibly
ever need in order
to agree on this thing?
And, if you think about
this for a minute,
you will see that
there's no finite bound
on the number of runners
that could possibly
be needed, because it's always
the case that a huge number
of runners could be
lost because this is
this best-effort network
where there's always
some probability of
something being lost.
There is always this
infinitesimal little chance
that a million runners in a
row wouldn't make it through.
So this is essentially
the two generals problem.
And what it says is it's
impossible for these two guys
to guaranty that they
will achieve consensus
about something using a
fixed number of messages,
using a fixed number of runners.
That means, in the case
of two-phase commit,
what that suggests is that
this S or one of these clients
may need to continually
retransmit, say,
an infinite number of times,
a very large number of times
before its request is
actually processed.
Because there's always this sort
of small chance of a message
being lost by the
best-effort network.
So that's the two
generals problem
and it's just sort of a
nice result to keep in mind.
It's one of those results
in computer science
that sometimes it turns
out to be important.
In practice, in this
kind of environment
it doesn't matter that much.
The probabilities
of loss are small.
And so most of the
time this is going
to achieve consensus after a
limited number of messages.
So that's it for our
discussion of fault tolerance
and recovery.
Next time we're going to
start talking about security
and protection of information.
We will see you on Monday.